c'est dans sa maison d'enfance et en toute
simplicité que sonia bompastor reçoit une
de ses admiratrices. Comme chaque été la
footballeuse professionnelle profite de ces
quelques jours de vacances pour se ressourcer
chez ses parents, à Mer, là où tout a commencé
pour elle. "j'ai toujours vécu à Mer jusqu'à
mon adolescence. c'est là où j'ai eu tous
mes copains et copines d'école et c'est là
où j'ai aussi commencé le football à l'âge
de 8 ans à l'US Mer en mixité avec les garçons.
Depuis elle en a écumé des pelouses : cinq saisons
à lyon et deux à Washington. Vainqueur cette
année du championnat de France de la coupe de
France et de la Champion's League son palmarès
suscite des vocations, comme celle de Manon.
"Faut pas avoir de regrets, c'est de travailler
énormément à l'entraînement et au match et tout
donner. Moi c'est toujours ce que j'ai fait"
"je pourrais y arriver peut-être avec
les conseils qu'elle m'a donnés"
Dans sa chambre elle conserve toujours
quelques souvenirs de ces rencontres sportives
hors du commun notamment les JO de Londres.
"A titre personnel je suis assez déçue
parce que je pense qu'on avait vraiment
les moyens d'aller chercher une médaille, en
tout cas c'était l'objectif qu'on s'était fixé
avant de partir là bas en Angleterre."
Sa carrière n'est pas terminée à 32
ans elle réattaque une nouvelle
saison comme capitaine à l'OL.
" je suis en train de faire mes valises
parce que je repars demain sur Lyon,
la saison redémarre lundi. J'ai rendez vous à 10
heures pour la visite médicale et quelques tests"
La valise bouclée et le moral regonflé,
Sonia entame sereine la saison prochaine.